a particle moves along the x-axis the
function x of t gives the particle's
position at any time t is greater than
or equal to zero and they give us x of t
right over here what is the particle's
velocity v of t at t is equal to 2. so
pause this video see if you can figure
that out
well the key thing to realize is that
your velocity as a function of time is
the derivative of position and so this
is going to be equal to we just take the
derivative with respect to t up here so
derivative of t to the third with
respect to t is 3 t squared if that's
unfamiliar i encourage you to review the
power rule
the derivative of negative 4 t squared
with respect to t is negative eight t
and derivative of three t with respect
to t is plus three derivative of a
constant doesn't change with respect to
time so that's just zero and so here we
have velocity as a function of time and
so if we wanna know our velocity at time
t equals 2 we just substitute 2 wherever
we see the t's so it's going to be 3
times 4 3 times 2 squared so it's 12
minus 8 times 2 minus 16
plus 3 which is equal to negative one
and you might say negative one by itself
doesn't sound like a velocity well if
they gave us units if they told us that
x was in meters and that t was in
seconds well then x would be well i
already said would be in meters and
velocity would be negative one meters
per second you might also be saying well
what does the negative means well that
means that we are moving to the left
remember we're moving along the x-axis
so if our velocity is negative that
means that x is decreasing or we are
moving to the left
what is the particle's acceleration a of
t at t equals 3. so pause this video
again and see if you can do that
well here the realization is that
acceleration as a function of time is
just the derivative of velocity which is
the second derivative of our position
which is just going to be equal to the
derivative of this right over here and
so i'm just going to get derivative of
3t squared with respect to t is 6t
derivative of negative 8t with respect
to t is minus 8. and derivative of
constant's 0. so it's just going to be
60 minus 8. so our acceleration at time
t equals 3 is going to be 6 times 3
which is 18
minus
8.
so minus 8 which is going to be equal to
positive 10.
all right now they ask us what is the
direction of the particle's motion at t
equals two well i already talked about
this but pause this video and see if you
can answer that yourself
well we've already looked at the sign
right over here the fact that we have a
negative sign on our velocity means we
are moving towards the left
so i'll fill that in right over there
at t equals 3 is the particle's speed
increasing decreasing or neither so
pause this video and try to answer that
all right now we have to be very careful
here if it says is the particle's
velocity increasing decreasing or
neither then we would just have to look
at the acceleration we see that the
acceleration is positive and so we know
that the velocity is increasing
but here they're not saying velocity
they're saying speed and just as a
reminder speed is the magnitude of
velocity so for example at time t equals
two our velocity is negative one if the
units were meters in second it would be
negative one meters per second but our
speed would just be one meter per second
speed you're not talking about the
direction so you would not have that
sign there
and so in order to figure out if the
speed is increasing or decreasing or
neither if the acceleration is positive
and the velocity is positive that means
the magnitude of your velocity is
increasing so that means your speed is
increasing if your velocity is negative
and your acceleration is also negative
that also means that your speed is
increasing but if your velocity and
acceleration have different signs well
that means that your speed is decreasing
the magnitude of your velocity would be
coming less so let's look at our
velocity at time t equals three our
velocity at time 3 we just go back right
over here it's going to be 3 times 9
which is 27 3 times 3 squared
minus 24
plus 3
plus 3. so this is going to be equal to
6.
so our velocity and acceleration are
both you could say in the same direction
they are both positive and so
our velocity is only going to become
more positive or the magnitude of our
velocity is only going to increase so
our speed is increasing
if our velocity was
negative at time t equals 3 then our
speed would be decreasing
because our acceleration and velocity
would be going in different directions